ALL RIGHT, NEW RULE FOR THE
NFL AS OF 2022.
A SECONDARY HELMET IS
PERMITTED. ONE IMPORTANT
CAVEAT
THOUGH IF YOU NEED THE
UNIFORM TO GO ALONG WITH THE
SECONDARY HELMET, IT'S TOO
LATE
TO
TO HAVE THE UNIFORM READY FOR
2022.
SO
WE MAY NOT SEE SOME OF THESE
UNTIL 2023 BUT
ARE DRAFTED A BEST HELMETS FOR
SECONDARY PURPOSES,
TRIVIA QUESTION, WHO HOLDS THE
BEARS FRANCHISE RECORD FOR
INTERCEPTIONS THROWN
BIG CAT?
IS IT
YOU DOING THIS TO HURT MY
FEELINGS?
NO,
NO TESTING YOUR KNOWLEDGE OF
YOUR FAVORITE TEAM. IS IT
ISN'T IT? YOU KNOW, YOU DON'T
CUTLER. IT'S IS IT.
NO,
IT'S GOOD LUCK. SID, LUCKMAN
FRANCHISE
PAUL, BECAUSE HE'S REALLY
STRONG. YEAH. YEAH.
THAT WAS THE OLD DAYS BACK
WHEN THEY HAD A LOT
INTERCEPTS. YEAH, CLOSE. THEY
USED TO HAVE A LOT
INTERCEPTIONS IN FOOTBALL. ALL
RIGHT, FIRST PICK FOR ME,
IT'S THE THE BUCCANEERS THE
CREAMSICLES. WE'RE NOT GOING
TO SEE THEM UNTIL 23,
BUT WITHOUT QUESTION I LOVE,
THERE, SO I KNOW IT'S GREAT,
PICK
IT INSTALLED YOU LISTEN, LET
ME ENJOY IT. LET ME ENJOY
THE TIME.
WAS A WORLD BEFORE YOU WERE
BORN,
THE
TEMPORARY PART OF MY WORLD.
THEY WERE BEAUTIFUL. I WANT
HIM BACK. ALL RIGHT, GO AHEAD.
YOU'RE UP. OKAY.
MINE IS I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU
DIDN'T GO TO NUMBER 1 HERE.
THE BEST ONES KELLY GREEN
PHILADELPHIA
EAGLES.
I LIKE THOSE NOT AS A FIRST
ROUND PICK, BUT I DO LIKE
THOSE
WERE IN, THE SHOULD GO BACK TO
THAT. THEY SHOULD GO BACK TO
THAT AS THEIR REGULAR UNIFORM.
THIS BEEN 20 YEARS OF THIS
OTHER WEIRD DARK GREEN
WITH THE WEIRD NUMBERS THEY
SHOULD GO BACK TO THAT. THAT
SHOULD BE THEIR BASE UNIFORM,
NOT AN ALTERNATE UNIFORM
PAT
PATRIOT. SECOND ROUND,
FINAL ANSWER. BRING IT BACK
20:23, WOULDN'T IT BE GREAT IF
SOMEHOW AND IT'S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN THIS YEAR, OBVIOUSLY,
BUT THE NEXT TIME THE BUCKS
AND THE PATRIOTS PLAY
FOR YEARS FROM NOW, WHEN TOM
BRADY IS STILL
THEY SQUARE OFF. THAT'S WHAT I
WOULD BE SOMETHING.
ARE YOU LEFT? YOU LITERALLY
LEFT THE BEST TO HELMETS ON
THE BOARD.
THE BEST TO KNOW YOU DIDN'T
THE BRONCOS LIGHT BLUE IS
THE BEST. THAT IS
INCREDIBLE. THAT'S AN
INCREDIBLE HELMET. THAT ONE
I'M VERY VERY EXCITED FOR.
LOOK AT THAT
WITH THE BIG D. COME ON.
THAT IS I JUST
DOMINATE. I DOMINATED YOU AND
I STILL HAVE A BIG LEFT
JUST MIKE FLORIO
FLORIO YOU STINK AT
REALITY.
LET ME, LET ME EXPLAIN THIS.
WE LIKELY WILL SEE THAT
ONE IN 2022 BECAUSE THE
BRONCOS ALREADY USED THE
OLD LOGO
ON THEIR DARK BLUE HELMET
AS THEIR COLOR RUSH UNIFORM
ANYWAY SO THEY DON'T NEED.
THEY DON'T NEED TO BE ABLE TO
SUBMIT PLANS FOR A NEW UNIFORM
TO GO WITH THE HELMET. I
SUSPECT THAT THEY'LL HAVE
THAT. NOW THEY HAVE TO LET
EVERYONE KNOW BY JULY 31,
WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO, BUT
I SUSPECT TO SEE THAT ON THE
FIELD IN 2022 NEXT
YEAR FOR ME AND THIS ISN'T
THROWBACK. THIS IS THIS IS
FAST FORWARD.
THIS IS THE
ANGLES GOING WITH THE
WHITE HELMET TO GO WITH THEIR
WHITE ON WHITE
UNIFORM, THE WHITE
SIBERIAN TIGER
UNIFORM, FOR THE BENGALS THAT
IS THE ONE THAT YOU SHOULD
HAVE TAKEN WITH YOUR FIRST TWO
PICKS
KNOW, YOU'RE NOT THINKING
FORWARD,
YOU'RE THINKING BACKWARD, WAIT
UNTIL THE BENGALS DO IT.
EVERYONE IS GOING TO LOSE
THEIR MINDS AND THEY'LL STILL
BE THE
BANGLE.
OH YEAH,
YEAH, THIS IS GOOD. SO WHO
GETS THE OILERS?
BLUE HELMETS. THOSE COOL.
THOSE COOL THROWBACKS WHO GETS
THAT
TITANS TITANS TITANS NOT THE
TEXANS EASY. THAT'S
AN EASY PICK. ANOTHER
BEAUTIFUL BEAUTIFUL HOME. LOOK
AT THAT HELMET. COME ON MIKE.
THAT'S A GOOD YOU AIN'T KNOW
WHAT THE F. DO YOU PREFER THE
WHITE DO YOU
PUT OUR THE BLUE? GIVE ME
BOTH.
THANK YOU. WE CAN DO THE WHITE
NOW.
RIGHT TO THE POINT. NOW, THEY
JUST PEEL THE PEEL OFF, THE,
THE DECALS AND PUT THOSE ON
DO THEY HAVE DARK HAIR?
THAT'S RIGHT. TO GET THAT THEY
GOT THE THAT'S RIGHT. THEY GOT
THE BOWLING BALL HELMETS. NOW
I FORGOT THAT THE TITANS GOT
RID OF THEIR WHITE
HELMET, SO YEAH, THEY COULD
EITHER ONE IS AN ALTERNATE
HELMET, THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO
PICK ONE OF THE OTHER SO YOU
WANT WHITER, YOU WANT BLUE?
LET ME KNOW. SO I CAN LOOK
LIKE BLUE KNOW WHAT YOU
PREFER.
LI